all right john carlo thank you for
joining us uh why did you want to take
on
this role they came to me with this
phenomenal idea
uh and had proposed that i play anton
castillo
the leader of yara with this big vision
and dream
for his country and it really appealed
to me because he was a guy who
first came from a love of his family and
a love of his
community and country and it was so in
in line with what's going on in the
world politically today
and what has happened in the past i
thought what a great opportunity
the other part of it is it's just a
different technology that's so brand new
and it excites me as a filmmaker that i
wanted to be a part of it
all right well you've played some
absolutely amazing villains in your
career what was it like being
a video game villain no i'm not a
villain
i have to i gotta push back on you i'll
let you finish
but this guy loves his country
he wants to empower you keely he wants
to empower
you to stand up and speak your truth
now you can go back to calling me a
villain if you like well you are smiling
on the box you're a good guy right
i am because i i feel like we as human
beings fall in line
and i i i want to be
a renegade within reason how do you like
that because i think
part and parcel of us falling in line
and doing what we need to do
and thinking about the cumulative effect
of our doing what's right and the
example of that
is also to stand up and say no
i do agree that they're good and bad
about all people but this guy
out of his love and passion for his
people even if they're faceless to him
at certain points in time
allow him to be an absolute hero
speaking of your character who did you
base him on or study to create this
character
it's so interesting because of course
the the obvious choice to study
is fidel castro and it is cuba
an island had so many resources but
really the
dream of the ability of the dictator to
cultivate those resources
something got in the way there and
hopefully that can change in the years
to come
if funny you asked me that question
because i was just talking to one of my
daughters about choices
and and uh also hitler uh
because we were talking about zodiac
signs and what signs for certain people
what is that mindset that has you
wanting to be have power over others
and for each dictator it's different
she'd never heard of trenches
and studied political science and all
this in college
so anyway so all right well one last
question for you uh
who would win in a square off between
gus fring
moff gideon and anton
you know and i have my favorites in
those two so you asked me this question
um and and you know immediately
i say moff gideon immediately
you know somehow i i think gus is colder
and displays that coldness in a very
particular way
uh you know i think anton
could be the most violent man on earth
uh but given his situation he may not be
rise to that occasion
or may not have the time moth giddy in
his otherworldly
this guy thinks in a different way and
he knows what you're thinking before you
say it
and he he does all his own dirty work
and he has
an incredible tool to help him out so
i'm going to save off cute
fair enough all right john carlo thank
you so much for hanging out with us
we will check out the revolution in far
cry 6.
and i can't wait for it to begin let the
games begin
awesome all right thank you so much john
carlos